we've come here today to speak to
christoph hoyskin in berlin for many
years he was angela merkel's foreign
policy advisor he was also germany's
ambassador to the united nations so he's
german one of germany's most senior
diplomats and he's now the chairman of
the prestigious munich security
conference ambassador thanks for joining
dw i want to start by talking about
um the diplomatic efforts that we see
ongoing at the moment between russia and
ukraine we are beginning to see the
possible controls of some kind of
agreement involving neutrality of
ukraine and ukraine receiving security
guarantees from outside guarantors do
you feel this is the kind of agreement
that could bring an end to this war
i have a fundamental problem and that is
that
over the years there have been many
agreements reached with russia
i remind you of the so-called budapest
memorandum in 94 where russia guaranteed
the
sovereignty and territory integrity of
ukraine and ukraine gave up its nuclear
weapons
i
recall the minsk agreement where
which was concluded after last time
russia invaded
ukraine it was an agreement which said
that there should be a ceasefire and
they should withdraw their heavy weapons
and the monetary should be allowed to
actually have
you know their freeway through all of
the dondas and russia didn't observe any
of this so my problem is that to agree
with russia today is very difficult
because russia under putin has lost all
credibility nobody trusts that russia
will actually then implement an
agreement it entered into and yet putin
is in power
this is the person who zelinski is
having to deal with volatilinski the
ukrainian president what choice does he
have but to negotiate no he doesn't have
a choice i just tell you what i think is
the outcome you cannot rely on this of
course zelensky has to he has to see to
it that he gets a ceasefire he has to
see to it that putin stops to bomb
civilians stops to commit
war crimes
now
if vladimir putin does go down this road
with an agreement of this type this
falls well short of the war aims that he
seemed to be professing at the beginning
of this war in those famous speeches he
made it made it sound like he had no
respect for ukraine as a sovereign state
um and that he essentially wanted to
affect regime change there
so what should we understand from the
fact that he seems to be considering an
agreement like this does it mean that he
feels he's losing in ukraine yes i think
that um he sees that what you know he
built up in his fantasy about a ukraine
that is very pro-russian where you have
a saudi government there and and and
there is no um ukrainian identity he
realizes that everything he thought
ukraine would be is is not it's not true
but um so he's on the defensive so i
think he has a certain interest in maybe
um
coming to a to a stop because they are
losing hundreds or thousands of soldiers
but
we must not forget you cannot trust
putin so he may then agree to something
but then he will regroup and try again
to to achieve you have to understand
what is real game is what is this he is
afraid that in russia something happens
that has happened in other countries in
the neighborhood that is that countries
that that the population is sick and
tired of this post-soviet oligarchic
society and he's afraid that this may
happen in russia as well so therefore he
has to stop all this and for him
a successful ukraine a ukraine that has
a prosperous industry a prosperous
economy where you have democracy and all
this this may be a nightmare for him
because people in in russia will ask how
about us and therefore he cannot allow
ukraine to succeed and now he sees that
all what is what he has been aiming for
is is crumbling
how weakened is putin i mean there's
been some speculation about whether
there could be a sort of palace coup
against him in russia do you think that
is something that is a realistic
prospect at the moment i cannot um you
know i have no idea how how this is
everybody says well you know in russia
this was under the czars and under
stalin you know they could do with their
population what they wanted to so there
is no danger for the ruler on the other
hand we see
you know on russian television we see in
the main news there is somebody standing
up for the journalists and then and this
sees that people are become much more
courageous it's wonderful what you have
from these young people that they risk
like navalny you know they risk going to
prison because they want another russia
so i think putin is in in serious
problems how serious i cannot tell you
how concerned are you i mean there's a
speculation also that putin goes in the
opposite direction he doesn't sign an
agreement he doesn't back down but he
doubles down he escalates his way
through this
how biggest concern is that for you
you you have to put yourself into
his shoes he sees that what he wanted to
achieve
was not able to he was not able to
achieve
and
he doesn't have any respect for
human rights for humanitarian law you
have seen what putin has done to the
citizen of grozny you have seen what
putin has done to the citizens of aleppo
so there may be a danger that he is
ready to double down yes and if he goes
ahead and does that what is the proper
response in your view from the west so
far the west has been remarkably united
in terms of imposing very tough
sanctions but it has stopped short of of
sanctions at least the europeans have on
energy
um is that a card that you feel that
germany and the rest of europe might at
some point be forced to draw
if putin seriously escalates
i think there has been really a
remarkable united front of all the
governments um and i this is not only
you know europe and the u.s you have
this worldwide
alliance of of countries the votes at
the u.n were overwhelming putin today is
supported is supported by kim jong-un by
assad and lukashenko can you imagine so
this is something which is really
remarkable
i've seen i'm i'm really
surprised by the amount of solidarity we
have in east european countries in my
own countries people want to support
ukraine that they see what putin is
doing
and of course to to go down in the
direction now of an energy of a gas
embargo is something very tough it has
serious it has serious repercussions but
um you know right now there are plans to
um also by the commission to
um see to it that we get faster to um an
independence of russian energy and i
think people are ready to um to go ahead
i think that people will not allow um
russia to do with kiev uh what he has
done to aleppo and what he has done also
to grosseni there are also more and more
quite serious voices
coming in and advocating
some
degree of intervention by nato whether
it is in trying to
create a so-called no-fly zone over
ukraine uh or there was a proposal um
from a polish side
on this trip to kiev
to create what they described as a nato
peacekeeping force could there come a
point where one of those options becomes
a more serious one i think this is
something the alliance has to discuss so
far
it is clear that nato as an organization
will not be involved this is in the
logic of the atlantic treaty this is why
also in in 2008 the basic decision was
taken that the ukraine and georgia that
was georgia at the time in the center of
discussion will
not get a membership and not become
member of nato because of the risk of a
direct confrontation of a third world
war so
i think we will not go that way not to
risk a world war but
everything that is possible below that
level i think one should discuss and see
how um how it is implemented and how
close are we getting to maybe even an
accidental clash of some kind we saw a
surveillance drone reportedly landing uh
in romania
um
we've got a lot of concern in poland and
other eastern nato flank countries about
what could happen
well this is something we have
we have lived through also during the
cold war um
russia and the united states the warsaw
pact and and nato
doing all these many years of of severe
political crisis were able to manage it
in a way that there was no that direct
confrontation and i'm
um actually pretty optimistic that this
doesn't happen
and if there are accidents that they
will be managed in a way that there is
no escalation i want to take a step back
at this point just to look at the bigger
global picture and particularly china
the americans are saying that russia has
requested support and that china is
already providing economic and financial
support to the russians
and
the americans saying that they are
considering providing military support
what happens if china does go down that
road if china starts quite actively
supporting russia does this then become
a proxy war between china and the west
well china has to make a choice um
china has been um also in the u.n where
it worked and everywhere they say and
and underline um you know the importance
of national sovereignty know when we
criticize china about what they do with
hong kong what they do with the urger
say you have nothing to do with it this
is national sovereignty
and now there is their partner russia
invading ukraine and violating national
sovereignty so i think that they have
they are at pain to to um you know
somehow um not support but tolerate it
be be kind to the russians so they are
in a real problem and they know if they
now start actively to support russia
that they are they lose their standing
as a country that is trying to have in
the world you know kind of an
alternative power country that stands
also for um you know
new power in the united nations that
respect sovereignty and
serves as kind of a model for other
countries if they go they know if they
go that way
they will lose credibility to a degree
that they they are not ready to accept
because then they are also
being siding with the paria state so i
have my doubt on the other hand of
course they they don't want to put in
and and and see are close so
c doesn't want to let putin down but he
knows that putin may drag him into
something which then has serious
repercussion because i'm sure that the
us and others are watching very
carefully and does he stay neutral or
does he get involved in an unacceptable
way on the side of russia
and what would be the appropriate
response for the west but also
particularly europe which has always
been walking it to some extent its own
line towards china
if china does make that move
what's the appropriate response for
europe i think we have to get
away from this notion of the west you
know we have to go to new york we have
to say this is international law what
russia is doing is violating
international law and if china then also
openly supports
russia in this i think we have to bring
it to the united nations say this is um
a country that is now not respecting
international law anymore but supporting
a country that is um um viral is is a
war basically a war criminal and
committing war crimes and i think we
should take it take it to the to the u.n
but of course also discuss it between
transatlantic partners but this goes
beyond you know what we are witnessing
here right now what russia is doing is
the violation of the very foundation of
the order that was established after the
second world war it's a violation of the
u.n charter it's a violation of the um
universal declaration of human rights so
this is nothing between west and east
this is actually an attack on the global
international order
christoph heisken thank you very much
for taking time to speak to us today
it's my pleasure thank you